und ich mach da jetzt naked bike
drausnigg
bedeutet nicht dass ihr die torte nackt
bagdad ich meine valentin ja ich bin ich
muss ehrlich sagen
dies schon süß geworden dessen kitschig
aber sie ist
es ist valentinstag
davon gibt's sein
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen sallys welt
valentinstag steht vor der tür und ich
möchte gerne eine torte backen ich weiß
dass viele von euch sich immer mal
wieder wald dienstags rezepte wünschen
und ich habe auch in den letzten jahren
schon einige hochgeladen letztes jahr
zum beispiel eine torte die war so
richtig süß und klein genau ausreichend
für zwei personen einen arzt orte da
dürft ihr auch gern mal vorbeischauen
heute gibt's einen ecke kate eine
richtig süßes valentinstags torte mit
ruby schokolade als topping ich werde
jetzt erstmal in bizkit herstellen weil
ein bizkit wirklich eins der tiger ist
oder 1er bizkit oder 1 der massen die
einfach super schnell gehen und vor
allem auch schnell backen das heißt ihr
habt dann nicht so eine extrem lange
backzeit und abkühlzeit weiß wirklich
schnell fertig in der küche und ich
mache jetzt erstmal den biskuit den
bereit ich jetzt mit mandeln zu um dem
ganzen einfach so ein schönes aroma zu
verleihen für den biskuit verwende ich
100 gramm mandeln die sind bereits
geschält und werden gleich gemahlen
sechs eier die sind schon zimmer war 150
gramm zucker etwas vanille extrakt eine
prise salz wer möchte gerne etwas
amaretto mit oder ohne alkohol 150 gramm
mehl dann nämlich ein ganz normales
weizenmehl nochmal 100 gramm mandeln zum
bestreut die sind auch gehobelt und etwa
50 gramm futter zu kommen und wie gesagt
hier entweder amaretto den klassischen
amaretto verwenden mit alkohol oder und
das zeigt sich jetzt einfach mal weil
immer wieder danach gefragt wird wo
gibt's denn alkoholfreien amaretto das
ist einfach so ein amaretto sirup da ist
praktisch bittermandel mit drin ihr
könnt aber auch ein peter mandelöl zum
beispiel nehmen und könnte damit so ein
bisschen diesen wandel geschmack einfach
ja verfeinern und so ein bisschen heraus
stechen lassen gut zum zerkleinern der
mangel nehme ich jetzt hier meinen mixa
[Musik]
ich nehme jetzt die gehobelten weil die
schon geschält sind ihr könnt aber auch
geschälte ganze mandel nehmen oder auch
schon gemahlene kaufen aber ich mal die
mandeln und nüsse eigentlich immer ganz
gerne selber und ich nehme die jetzt in
geschälter variante damit der teig schön
hell bleibt und sich eben nicht dunkel
verfärbt denn die torte wird seine
pastellrosa eine torte
[Musik]
ok jetzt gebe ich die zimmer waren eier
in die rührschüssel zimmer waren
deswegen weil sie sich dann voluminöse
aufschlagen und das ist bei einem biss
wird echt wichtig dann den zucker dazu
dann vanille extrakt und
[Musik]
salz und da könnt ihr das ganze schön
verrühren und wenn ihr jetzt sagt ihr
wollt nicht so extrem lange rühren bis
wird es nämlich wichtig lange zu rühren
etwa 15 minuten bis der bis die eier
masse fast sogar steif geschlagen ist
dann könnt ihr nämlich mit normalem mehl
arbeiten wenn ihr aber sagt es nur noch
schneller gehen und blitz biscuit dann
neben dir am besten backpulver und mehl
oder verwendet mein bike mehl backpulver
schon mit dabei und dann reicht's auch
wenn ihr die eier masse einfach kurz
schaumig rühren und daneben mehl mit
backpulver dazu gibt dann geht er bis
wird auch schon auf aber so ein
klassischer bis geht es wirklich
eigentlich ohne backpulver
[Musik]
und hier gibt dir jetzt amaretto mit
dazu
[Musik]
richtig schön und jetzt immer schön
drauf achten und nicht im schnee wesen
an den rand klopfen sonst glaubt ihr die
ganze luft wieder raus die ihr schön
eingerührt habt dann könnt ihr jetzt das
mehl dazu 7
[Musik]
komm jetzt hier noch die gemahlenen
mandeln dazu
und werden ganz vorsichtig untergehoben
ich habe die öfen bereits vorgeheizt ich
pack das ganze 10 3 bringen wenn ihr
keine drei bagger habt könnt ihr einfach
nur einen nehmen den bis gut einfühlen
dann hat er einfach eine längere bauzeit
und ihr könnt ihn später durchschneiden
wenn hier schön gleichmäßig verstreichen
es geht am besten mit seiner tiefen
winkt die palette
und dann kommen jetzt hier die gehobelte
mandeln drauf es gibt unseren richtig
schön kross obendrauf wie bei einem
bienenstich
und zum abschluss heute noch ein
bisschen puderzucker drüber
und dann kommen die so in den backofen
für etwa 25 bis 30 minuten bis sie gar
sind und ich kann ihn da
zwischenzeitlich schon mal und socket
dekoration kümmern
[Musik]
jetzt sind die schoko lolies an der
reihe für die torte habe ich mir das
nämlich überlegt dass das süße kleine
schokoherzen draufkommen ich habe es
nämlich ganz neu wem so silikon förmchen
gemacht die eben für schoko nuss oder
für zucker lollis ganz gut geeignet sind
falls ihr welche aus zucker machen wollt
dann könnt ihr dafür isomalt verwenden
isomalt ist praktischen
zuckeraustauschstoff dem auch ganz gerne
mal nimmt wenn man einfach keinen echten
normalen raffinierten zucker nehmen
möchte ihr sollt schmilzt nämlich und
hat nicht diese eigenschaft dass es
sofort karamellisiert hat praktischen
anderen schmelzpunkt und deswegen bleibt
auch ganz kristallklar und man kann eben
damit tolle figuren machen und ich habe
die ein stern und rund und als herzchen
und da ist jetzt eine valentinstag sorte
ist gibt's herzchen und
dafür haben wir hier noch so cake pops
ticks gemacht diese logistics und die
sind wieder verwendbar
ich finde es nämlich immer ziemlich
schade wenn man die alle immer
wegschmeißt und sind wir mal ganz
ehrlich gerade wenn es bei uns cake pops
oder lolli sticks oder sowas gibt dann
bleiben die meist auch bei uns und
selbst wenn wir sie immer wo hin
mitnehmen kann man die sticks wieder mit
zurücknehmen und dann hat man die eben
die gibt es auch in verschiedenen farben
also schwarz weiß rosa und hellblau und
ich nehme sie die weißen und die commerz
ihr rein gehen die silikon form einfach
so bis zur mitte und ich werde gleich
meine schokoladen lollis ausruf
schokolade machen das ist die vierte
schokoladensorte neben weißer vollmilch
und zartbitter schokolade und die ist
praktisch von natur aus rosa weil die
kakaobohne ebenso entdeckt wurde von
calais bord von barry callebaut und es
hat wirklich jahre lang gedauert bis man
dann endlich herausgefunden hatte wie
man diese kakaobohne die farbe der
kakaobohne erhält oder ist einfach so
ein bisschen zitronensäure mit dabei
deswegen schmeckt die auch so leicht
fruchtig und säuerlich richtig richtig
lecker und deswegen ist die so richtig
schön rosa und ich hab jetzt hier das
ganze schon aufgeteilt in zwei drittel
eintritten und die schokolade die muss
jetzt auf jeden fall temperiert also vor
kristallisiert werden damit sie den
schönen glanz hat und eben keinen grauen
schleier bekommt dafür gebe ich jetzt
zwei drittel davon hier in der schmelz
schale hier habe ich schon wasser
aufgesetzt habs aufkochen lassen und den
herd ausgemacht und jetzt warte ich
einfach bis die schokolade schmilzt
[Musik]
so ein paar minuten später ist jetzt
perfekt ich stelle das jetzt nicht so
gerne hier auf der granitplatte ab weil
es ansonsten einfach zu kalt ist
deswegen gration silikon patch herunter
oder schneidebrett zum beispiel und dann
kommt das restliche drittel dazu das ist
zum einen zum herunterkühlen und eben
auch weil diese schokoladen jobs einfach
schon die perfekte kristallstruktur
haben und die flüssige schokolade
sozusagen dann auch in diese richtung
geht und dann habt ihr die perfekte
schokolade das ganze nennt sich eben
methode hatten im finish zu tun aber ich
merke immer auch in meinen stories das
dann instagram immer die worte impfen
das wort impfen zum beispiel versteht
und dann immer eine impfzentrale die er
sofort vermittelt das hat aber nichts
mit schokoladen import
jetzt einfach schön rühren man merkt
auch direkte konsistenz verändert sich
und dann muss die schokolade wenn sie
jetzt gleich komplett geschmolzen ist
wohl noch einmal ganz kurz erwärmt
werden man kühlt sie praktisch runter
also es gibt immer so eine
temperaturkurve erste wird die
schokolade erwärmt dann wird sie
herunter gekühlt und dann nur noch ein
bisschen erhitzt und dann ist sie
wirklich perfekt
und das mache ich gleich indem ich sie
noch mal aufs wasser bat sätze oder mit
einem heißluft füllen falls ihr einen
habt wenn ich dann einfach nur noch mal
kurz drauf setzen
mobil
[Musik]
und egal wie sehr ihr schon oder wie
geübt ihr schon im schokolade
temperieren seit eine schokolade pro ist
immer ganz wichtig um zu testen ob es
wirklich auch alles funktioniert hat das
muss ich sagen habe ich die letzten
jahre auch nie gemacht oder hat es mal
geklappt man nicht so gut geklappt aber
es kann einfach sein dass es einfach mal
nicht so gut temperiert und vor
kristallisiert ist deswegen nehmt ihr
euch am besten unsere teig karte tunken
bisschen die spitze ein und legt sie
jetzt hier auf die arbeitsfläche nicht
zu nah an den rand also nicht zu nah an
den herd rand weil da ist es ja immer
wärmer als jetzt dort und jetzt warte
ich eine minute und wenn dann die
schokolade schön anzieht und festwirten
schönen glanz hat dann ist sie perfekt
und ich kann sie weiter benutzen falls
sie nach einer minute immer noch nicht
fest ist heißt sie ist vielleicht noch
zu warm dann müsst ihr einfach noch mal
ein paar schoko drops dazu geben also
einfach weiter dazu impfen
wenn die schokolade dann perfekt ist und
keine klümpchen mehr aufweist könnt ihr
zum beispiel nur sehr flasche nehmen
damit lässt sich die schokolade perfekt
einfüllen oder ihr könnt sie auch mit
einem löffel einfüllen oder mit einer
spritztour zum beispiel
und dann kann jetzt schokolade
eingefüllt werden am besten bisschen was
unter das stäbchen
dann das stäbchen rein und schön
ausfüllen
am besten noch klopfen damit die luft
entweicht
dann verteilt sich die quartiere auch
gut
[Musik]
und ohne tabu
paar monaten
richtig schön und so kommen die jetzt
erst mal in den kühlschrank und stufen
fest werden und so lange kann ich mich
schon mal kommt die torte wieder kümmern
jetzt geht's an die creme ich habe mir
gedacht ich mache einfach eine himbeere
erdbeer creme die ist sehr sehr lecker
und ich mag es nicht furchtbar gerne
dafür verwende ich 200 gramm himbeeren
und 200 gramm erdbeeren aus dem
tiefkühlfach 100 milliliter wasser eine
tüte ag zum pflanzenschutz mittel etwas
tonka passte 800 frischkäse im doppel
ram stufe 400 gramm sahne 100 gramm
puderzucker und etwas sonderbar zum
steif schlagen und zudem durch am besten
etwas größeren topf da kommen die
früchte reihen ihr könnt auch wenn ihr
sagt ihr mögt keine himbeeren oder
erdbeeren nimmt einfach gerne andere
früchte aber ich hätte halt schon ganz
gerne dass die creme recht rosa wird
dann bis zu stampfen
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt das wasser dazu mit dem
acker
[Musik]
ob gebracht
dann gebe ich da jetzt noch die tanker
passte dazu ihr könnt auch manuell
extrakt nehmen aber tom pappas echt
perfekt zu früchten und dann wandert das
ganze schon direkt auf dein herz ich
lasse es auf kochen und dann mindestens
zwei minuten lang sprudelnd kochen ihr
könnt hier sogar 34 minuten kochen dann
verdunstet noch so ein bisschen die
flüssigkeit darin
und ich kann es jetzt ja auch einstellen
ich stelle hier am herd vier minuten ein
und dann läuft die uhr von alleine ab
und daher schaltet sich aus da muss ich
da gar nicht macht geben ich rühre
einfach nur ab und zu ein bisschen durch
[Musik]
jetzt ist alles fertig und entweder lass
dir so einfach abkühlen oder wenn ihr
sagt ihr möchtet diese himberg kerne
nicht mit drin haben dann könnte es auch
werden durch ein sieb streichen
dann ist alles entfernt und die creme
ist später schön aromatisch lecker und
rosa hat aber nicht diese störung dem
hinweg kennen und dann lasse ich das
ganze abkühlen und kann danach eben die
sahne creme zu beenden bz ihr ganz gut
die masse ist schön kalt und ich habe
jetzt ein bisschen warten müssen so 10
15 minuten und habe dann in der
zwischenzeit die 2 sahne und frischkäse
einfach wieder kalt gestellt also da
achtet ihr bitte darauf dass sahne und
quark und alles mögliche was ihr habt
frischkäse immer schön kalt ist für so
eine creme denn ansonsten gelingt durch
die creme vielleicht nicht dann gewinnt
die sahne da kommt jetzt der frischkäse
dazu am besten noch butter zucker
dazugeben
und glatt rühren
[Musik]
und dann kommt hier die saale langsam
dazu
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sobald die sahne angerührt ist könnt ihr
sonder partner zu geben das ist einsame
stadt mittel was ich unglaublich gerne
verwende einfach dazu nehmen und die
creme schön schreibt schlagen
[Musik]
und so sollte sie dann aussehen eine
richtig schöne creme die kommt jetzt in
den kühlschrank ich kann hier aufräumen
und noch die bizkit böden holen
die böden hatte ich jetzt kurz draußen
auf der terrasse steht ich muss da
aufpassen weil sonst die katzen immer
dran gehen die riechen dass da draußen
es kommen immer mehr katz und so ins auf
den hof aber ich denke immer schön ab
und beschwert das ganze mit orten retter
dann kann da keine katze dran und jetzt
sind sie schön kalt
man kann nicht so schön herauslösen
den ersten boden setzt sich jetzt direkt
auf meines diese tortenplatte die passt
einfach perfekt hose und ich mache da
jetzt naked bike
drauflegt bedeutet nicht dass er die
torte nackt sondern dass die torte außen
eben nicht mit einer creme verziert wird
weil die torte an sich einfach schon
schön ist und wenn ihr so eine schöne
torte habt mit seinen standorten
abschluss ganz einfach macht naked cache
das ist immer für eine spritztour eines
16 mm machtfülle
na habt ihr am besten die spitze immer
so ein bisschen um stellt hier ein
und seitdem in der hand frei und da
kommt jetzt die creme rein ich mache
jetzt mal nicht die komplette creme rein
ansonsten ist echt so viel und jetzt
also ich bin rechtshänder deswegen ist
bei mir die rechte hand oben die linke
hand führt nur und ich wäre gern
spritzbeutel oben immer schön zu da hat
man druck drauf
[Musik]
warum das hat doch einen mann gemacht
dass man das dann auch so alles nennt
der spritzbeutel interessiert hat sich
halt ohne besser an
interessierte
[Musik]
also hier oben die maschinen zu drehen
damit man einfach einen guten druck hat
[Musik]
flipboard so einfach senkrecht
okay jetzt
haltet ihr den sprit- und
[Musik]
jetzt haltet ihr mit der rechten hand
wenn die rechtshänder sind hier oben
einen spritzbeutel zu
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
hat sich oben den spritzbeutel immer
schon zu halten
[Musik]
die oben den spritzbeutel zu halten die
zweite hand gehört wollte hat jetzt
ihren schritten eine senkrecht und tupft
hieraus ein tupfer drauf wir sollten
auch von außen schön aussehen ach ist
das schön
denn hier die mitte so ein bisschen
verstreichen
dann kommt da der zweite boden drauf
wenn ihr übrigens das ganze also diese
zwar nicht ganz so schön hinbekommt dann
gibt es auch einen trick ich
zeige ich dass man hier dass man eben
dieses abgezockter außen nicht sieht
könnt ihr hier auch außen so ansetzen
und diese tupfer so machen dann hat die
außen immer so einen perfekten abschluss
[Musik]
si
und dann den dritten boden aufsetzen
und wenn ihr möchtet könnt ihr jetzt die
oberfläche auch noch mit tupfen befüllen
und da mache ich jetzt wirklich so dass
ich sie so auch spritze das außen schön
ist und innen spritzig und oberrhein
[Musik]
jetzt ist die torte soweit schon mal
fertig die kommt in den kühlschrank
damit die creme schon fest werden kann
ich mach hier sauber und dann schaue ich
direkt mal wie die lollies aussehen
sobald die kuvertüre fest ist könnt ihr
die lollies schön raus lösen
[Musik]
ich habe es hier noch mal ein bisschen
ruby schokolade geschmolzen und
temperiert die fülle ich hier in einem
kleinen spritzbeutel ein den rest könnt
ihr übrigens immer aufbewahren und beim
nächsten mal einfach wieder verwenden
ich fülle die schokolade die flüssige
immer ganz gerne in eiswürfel behälter
mit deckel bekommen sie einen
kühlschrank und wenn sie fest sind kann
ich sehr einfach im vorratsschrank
verstauen und habe dann einfach die
kuvertüre immer da
weiße kuvertüre auch die callebaut habe
ich jetzt auch schon geschmolzen
denn damit werden die lollies schön aus
dekoriert und in diesen mini
spritzbeutel
mache ich gern so ich nehme so kleine
clips ihr könnt auch haargummis
verwenden
dann schneidet ihr eine kleine spitze
weg und für die deko nämlich noch hier
diese schokoladen flex diese nämlich
richtig richtig schön und glänzend vor
allem toll und dann nehme ich hier
abwechselnd einmal rosa und weiße
schokolade teufel das so drüber in
schönen streifen
[Musik]
ihr könnt auch gerne was schreiben zum
schreiben eignet sich dann aber am
besten wenn ihr die schokolade mit und
ganz wenig wasser verdünnt ich zeige
euch das einfach mal gleich und dann
läuft die schokolade nicht mehr so also
dann bleiben diese linien auch wirklich
perfekt obwohl man ja immer sagt was er
darf nicht an die schokolade aber zum
schreiben ist es wirklich immer gut wenn
ihr mit kuvertüre schreiben wollt und
die kuvertüre nicht mit wasser vermischt
ist dann läuft sie so ein bisschen
auseinander ich zeige euch das mal mit
diesem spritzbeutel da kann ich nämlich
hier ansetzen
[Musik]
und man sieht es ihr ganz gut ist bleibt
so ein bisschen in form aber läuft
trotzdem aus sondern weil ich kann diese
feinen linien nicht machen deswegen
nehmt ihr euch ein bisschen kuvertüre
und dann gebt ihr da tröpfchenweise
warmes wasser dazu
wirklich nur tröpfchenweise denn wenn es
ein bisschen zu viel ist weil ist die
kuratorin schon kaputt aber ich glaube
so ein bisschen was dass sie eben nicht
so davon rennt man merkt dann auch
gleich die konsistenz wird ca
so ist gut
möglich so ein tropfen zu viel und die
quartiere ist einfach nicht mehr so gut
aber dann könnt ihr immer noch ein
bisschen was von der dazu geben dann
gehts orbiter und jetzt zeige ich euch
mal wie ich mit dem schreiben
und da sieht man einfach gleich dass es
viel viel dünner geht und einfach
gleichmäßiger bleibt und ihr wirklich
auch schön die struktur seht also
normalerweise kann man sich auch so eine
mini spritzt öle oder tüte aus
packpapier rollen das ist aber muss ich
sagen so ein bisschen sinn handgriffe
die man vielleicht nicht sofort drauf
hat und deswegen ist ein mini
spritzbeutel echt ganz praktisch und ihr
könnt ihr entscheiden wie weit ihre
praktische einschneidet und so öffnet
ihr eben nach vorne dieser spritztour
sozusagen also je mehr weg schneidet
umso dicker wird die schrift und je
dünner ihres vorne last umso dünner und
feiner wird ich lass das ganze jetzt
kurz hier trocknen und aushärten und
dann denken wir jetzt die torte fertig
mir wird das ganze jetzt ein bisschen zu
hoch deswegen setze ich doch auf eine
weiße platte sonst ist glaube zu
kitschig da kommt es rosa und immer gut
durch ja so schön dann ist das jetzt
hier ein naked cache und um drauf kommen
diese schokolade
[Musik]
dies schon süß geworden es sind kitschig
aber siehst aber kommt es ist
valentinstag
darf mal kitschig sein jetzt hole ich
mal meinen valentin danach nehme ich
jetzt probieren ihr wisst ja liebe geht
durch den magen
ich würde es natürlich ein murat
[Musik]
da
[Applaus]
am dienstag immer darum
bitte ich will mich dass man das jetzt
gefehlt ja du hast du dich mein valentin
ja ich bin eben muss ehrlich sagen ich
bin gefühl gefühlt nicht nur noch bei
weihnachten und
neujahr schon jetzt kommt ein feiertag
nach so einer hat er dann den kompletten
januar sonst haben wir verpennt weil er
sondern hat rein kommt und dann sehe ich
denke das war gerade weihnachten
silvester auch jetzt schon februar ja
dass man das jahr fängt es schon toll an
kfz versicherung gestiegenen strompreis
bestiegen gaspreis gestiegen dann denkst
du ja auch genial jetzt macht dass man
sich nicht komplett
alles koalition valentinstag mein schatz
danke dir da hat mir wieder eine torte
gebacken zum valentinstag das ist
richtig schön richter und wetzig ganz
gerne
also das ist die valentinstags torte ok
hat er okay so lässig cool ich bin
überrascht dass man so was machen kann
noch mehr
probieren sie auch richtig toll aus ja
ich freue mich auf die logische roulade
auch peres 6
14 jahre und damit schätze noch 14 jahre
jetzt und haben nur 14 februar also
nicht auch ein 14 14 februar
valentinstag was ich normalerweise für
sie das rezept ist sie vorher gemacht
hat es wissen und nicht ganz schön
romantisch echt haben wir nicht das
arbeit dieses jahr das natürlich in die
öffentlichkeit tragen
[Musik]
gespannt das muss ich dann am 14 februar
für mich nach wacken
das wollen wir natürlich alle sehen ich
muss das schön machen aber wie schon
gesagt dass ruby schokolade ist wirklich
einer meiner schule an was ich nicht so
mag ist so weiße schokolade ich habe als
kleines kind habe ich mir diese weißen
tafeln ganz gegessen und
ich hätte mir das dann doch mit gottes
bieten wir sind so lang verheiratet das
mir sowas noch machen müssen hier ist
richtig
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
gut ich muss auch ehrlich sagen jetzt
die ganzen tag nichts gegessen nicht so
leicht
reiswaffeln
dafür liebe ich nicht einfach weil ja
also das
essen aber kuchen und törtchen sondern
vielleicht auch weil ich ein netter
mensch bin
aber backen kann so auch deswegen habe
man muss einen kleinen vorteil mal
richtig entscheidung nicht zu heiraten
war mir im nachhinein betrachtet war es
richtig hier danke schön danke
also das war meine diesjährige
valentinstags torte und nicht so nah
nicht so nah wie hatte doch gerne mal
aus und ließ die erst mal klein aber
alleine können wir die tonne nicht essen
als hobby so viel ihr könnt ja aber auch
so mini mini törtchen machen wenn ihr
zum beispiel
das kommt wirklich nur eine kleine
portion macht dann rechnet doch den
biskuit runter auf ein ei zum beispiel
als ein sechstel der menge nimmt nimmt
diese mini burger ringe und dann könnt
ihr so eine minden zum mädchen waren
wegen sie nur für eine person und er
könnte sechs kreuzchen machen falls ihr
verschiedene personen habt eine person
lieben ich denke natürlich deswegen habe
ich einige machen vielleicht gibt die am
6 hinter dates und dann zack zack zack
zack kriegt jeder
anders und viel spaß oder ich weiß nicht
sagt die spaß am valentinstag
ja
einmal die torte
[Musik]